[Musique]
Chantal Hébert Michel David José le beau
bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir monsieur grendez
qui est donc à convoquer la presse à
midi aujourd'hui pour s'excuser pour
dire ben oui c'est moi qui l'avais écrit
j'ai dit pendant 10 ans que c'est pas
moi j'avais honte dit-il tout ça a été
très dur on écoute un extrait de ce de
ce point de presse
pour nous c'est de regarder notre santé
mentale
la santé d'un mentale de moi-même il est
important
mais c'est pas le plus important ce qui
est important
c'est
la santé mentale de mes enfants et
ma femme
il a il a expliqué qu'il a parlé à Paul
saint-pierre-la-mondon il a envoyé une
lettre à madame Marois lui a répondu
donc il est dans un processus de
d'excuse et les gens reconnaissent on
voit le tweet de Monsieur Paul
Saint-Pierre Plamondon qui dit nous
saluons le fait que Monsieur grindé
reconnait ses prennent l'entière
responsabilité de ses protos et de ses
propos etc alors ce qui est dramatique
Chantal Hébert je commence avec vous
c'est il aurait fait ça avant l'annonce
de son emploi et les gens auraient dit
bon ben la rédemption ça existe mais là
après c'est comme si bon plus difficile
c'est comme si à la réaction qui a suivi
l'annonce de son embauche il y avait
pris la mesure de ce qu'il avait fait il
y a 10 ans c'est quand même long 10 ans
peut-être que le premier mois on se dit
c'était une bonne idée mais à un moment
donné quelque part en chemin c'était
quand même lourd les commentaires de de
ce monsieur et ce qu'on voit sans douter
de sa sincérité c'est aussi une
tentative maintenant qui a repris la
mesure de se refaire une réputation qui
va lui permettre de continuer à
travailler oui Michel oui je l'écoutais
et puis je me demandais est-ce que c'est
le fond de ce qu'il a fait qu'il
regrette à ce point où les conséquences
manifestement extrêmement difficile que
ça a eu pour pour sa famille et ses
enfants en particulier qui ont devine
facilement ont dû passer des journées
extrêmement difficiles alors ceci étant
dit
écoutez sa valeur sincère on peut pas si
madame Marois qui qui la première
avoir de la difficulté à devrait être la
première avoir du sculpter à faire
donner à rive à le faire je pense qu'on
doit tous faire la même chose mais il
est certain que comme du Chantal ça a
été bien long avant qu'il réalise
oui ben je suis d'accord est-ce que mes
collègues viennent de dire moi mon
problème c'est plus avec la décision du
siècle de Montréal ça change pas de
l'avoir nommé sans que ce travail-là au
préalable était fait Slate a dit oui je
pense que quiconque le vieux aujourd'hui
peut pas douter de la sincérité et ce
qui m'a frappé d'un point de vue sur le
produit plus humain c'est que
d'après ce qu'il décrivait ce qu'il
avait vécu depuis la semaine dernière
c'est un peu comme s'il avait vécu ce
que madame Marois a vécu je parle pas de
la tentative d'assassinat ils ont reçu
des menaces de mort ses enfants ont
extrêmement souffert là il a su ce que
c'était être attaqué sur les médias
sociaux parce que ce qui le dit disait
là ça alimentait tout ça contre Pauline
Marois côtes aussi des souverainiers
c'était pas juste des accords politiques
c'est vraiment du langage haineux c'est
un appel au meurtre ou dans le cas de
madame Marois c'est c'est plus que
excuse je pense qu'on a assisté à
quelque chose qui ressemble à une
expiation pendant le sens religieux du
terme et et
éventuellement une réconciliation est-ce
qu'il a dit aussi sur le Québec c'était
très important qu'il le disent que le
Québec avait accueilli ses parents et
qu'ils étaient fiers de dire que le
Québec était à leur maison donc
je pense que ce qu'il y avait à Eddy a
été dit malheureusement ça peut être
éducatif
j'imagine que j'aimerais pouvoir la
refaire autrement mais c'est comme ça le
combat des infirmières c'est intéressant
Chantal vous nous avez écrit pour le
même ouvert le Téléjournal avec le 17h
avec ça tout à l'heure on va écouter ce
qui était pas avec nous docford il
voulait vous en infirmière médecin je
vais prendre tout ce qui parle et non
seulement venez mais je vais vous
faciliter la vie pour les papiers et
tout ça les approbations les ordres
professionnels on écoute monsieur four
immédiatement il savez-vous dans toutes
les provinces font face au même défi on
a tous intérêt d'ici la recruter du
personnel à l'international touchez pas
que nous infirmières s'il vous plaît on
va essayer d'aller sur la planète Michel
David première réaction ouais monsieur
Dubé probablement pensé des choses qui
est pas dites à propos de Monsieur Ford
dans l'écoutant essayer de lui voler
puis moi ces infirmières après la
semaine que Monsieur Dubé a vécu
maintenant ceci étant dit Monsieur Ford
écoutez je sais pas dans quelle mesure
ça va être entendu mais j'imagine que
les infirmières ou n'importe qui qui
regardent des politiques de Monsieur
Ford va dire écoutez ce gouvernement est
en appel d'un jugement qui a invalidé
une loi qui visait à plafonner n'est
plus ni moins les salaires pendant trois
ans
d'autre part monsieur ford vient
d'annoncer qu'il agissait passablement
contrôle des cliniques privées alors il
essaie de récupérer d'une certaine façon
les infirmières qu'ils risquent de
perdre
au secteur privé alors au total j'ai pas
convaincu que son opération va être
couronnée de succès à ce point-là mais
c'est certain que la belle amitié entre
monsieur Ford et monsieur Legault va
peut-être disons connaître des
un certain assombrissement oui en même
temps les gens vont dire c'est vrai
quand monsieur Legault dit qu'on n'est
pas tout seul dans ce domaine dans ce
bateau là la preuve en cherche mais il
souhaite qu'ils partent pas vers
l'Ontario José
oui sauf que petite parenthèse au Québec
il ne manque pas d'infirmière il manque
d'infirmière dans le réseau public et
dans certains cas de travail alors ça je
pense qu'il faudrait quand même le dire
clairement parce qu'on voit c'est un
petit snow finalement
[Musique]
décidé de faire du maraudage c'est pas
le premier
corrigez-moi je me souviens plus c'était
le premier ministre du Manitoba ou de la
Saska avec la loi 21 qui avait dit nous
on vous jugera pas ce que vous portez
sur la tête ou est-ce que vous avez dans
la tête il y avait midi publicités au
Québec pour recruter les enseignantes
dans sa province donc c'est pas nouveau
mais dans le contexte actuel c'est sûr
que c'est de c'est de très mauvais goût
mais dans la région de l'outaway
peut-être que Chantal pourrait pour être
confirmer dans la région de l'outaway où
au Québec c'est vraiment le système de
santé est encore en pire état que dans
le reste de la province il y a déjà
beaucoup de maraudages depuis longtemps
il y a déjà du personnel médical qui
passe à l'Ontario c'est pas c'est pas
nouveau comme phénomène Chantal et qui
sont pas obligés pour autant de changer
leur résidence donc il reste dans le
même marché économique au niveau de
l'habitation et qui a pas de santé bon
l'annonce de Monsieur Ford ça fait deux
en deux semaines parce que avant ça il y
a eu le point de presse où il disait des
conditions amenez-en moi je suis prêt à
accepter tant que Monsieur Trudeau
m'envoie de l'argent ça allait un petit
peu beaucoup plus loin que ce que le
front des provinces avait laissé
entendre jusqu'à présent
le problème du Québec parce que moi je
crois qu'on s'en va sur cette voie là
que la plupart des provinces vont lever
ces conditions-là pour faciliter le
recrutement des du personnel médical
d'ailleurs au Canada en passant c'était
pas si rigoureux là en Ontario le
collège des infirmières l'association
qui a créditent c'est un délai de 30
jours en principe dont on parle et
normalement c'est assez marginal le
nombre d'infirmières formés dans
d'autres provinces qui veulent ou qui
demandent une accréditation mais le
problème du Québec c'est quand on
s'embarque là dedans
les les personnages de la santé
québécoise est beaucoup plus susceptible
d'avoir une grande mobilité ailleurs au
Canada s'il le désir que le Québec d'en
attiré ici pour des raisons linguistique
évidentes c'est pas juste en Ontario à
peu près n'importe qui qui va se
présenter va être capable de se
débrouiller et travailler en anglais
très rapidement ou demain matin mais
l'inverse c'est pas vrai une infirmière
qui veut quitter l'Alberta choisira pas
nécessairement le Québec parce qu'elle
ne parle pas français alors ça Aguire ce
que de compliqué effectivement
singulièrement la tâche du ministre Tubé
et il y a pas de raison d'être très très
heureux de ça
très bien rencontre
monsieur Legault qui poursuit ses
rencontres individuelles avec les chefs
de l'opposition les différents chefs on
n'a pas été autour de Monsieur Tanguay
aujourd'hui et vous allez voir le ton il
y a des petits oiseaux autour comme hier
d'ailleurs
il y a beaucoup de petits oiseaux à Éric
on le souligné hier lui ça le donne le
ça lui donne
ça le conforte dans sa place donc sur
l'échiquier politique d'être reçu par le
Premier ministre monsieur Tanguy qui est
le chef de la position officielle voici
ce qu'il a dit sur une conversation
qu'il veut
qu'il veut encourager sur la révolution
énergétique entre les Québécois et le
gouvernement
savoir ce que l'on fait faut savoir
comment on va le faire et c'est
important la transition énergétique là
c'est maintenant mais nous avons un
potentiel extraordinaire au Québec avec
Willy droélectricité avec l'éolien avec
peut-être la recherche et développement
sur des moyens de consommation beaucoup
plus locales et de stockage d'énergie
nous devons avoir cette conversation là
alors José je commence avec vous
monsieur Lego il coûte 5 mais très bien
moi je veux je ne veux que parler de ça
de toute façon
oui oui ben c'est vraiment cette parade
qui se poursuit et qui a quand même son
importance parce que bon évidemment
c'est très difficile pour les parties
d'opposition face à un gouvernement qui
est aussi massivement majoritaire à
cause du mode de scrutin mais
on s'en va le vers la session là va
siéger très bien tôt et et mon petit
doigt me dit que les parties
d'opposition parce qu'ils ont plus le
choix vont guerroyer quand même assez
dur là bon évidemment particulier va
voir qu'il réalise l'imagination parce
qu'il y aura pas beaucoup de questions
mais quand même on a vu que vos droits
étaient capable de terrain quand il veut
et donc et que des crises aussi le
gouvernement à plusieurs crises à gérer
donc il est il n'est pas fragile dans
les intentions de vote mais il est
fragile sur sa gestion et sa gouvernance
du Québec en ce moment donc moi je pense
que c'est c'est plus le prélude à
[Rires]
j'avoue que j'ai pas entendu dans votre
extrait une idée
extraordinairement forte et différente
des projets de François Legault ou même
une critique de ses projets j'imagine
que ça viendra mais dans le cas de ce
dossier là la transition énergétique
les problèmes qui attendent le
gouvernement viendront pas d'abord des
parties de position à l'Assemblée
nationale ça va venir de l'extérieur
quand il va y avoir plus de précisions
quand on va savoir de quoi on parle
exactement de quel territoire rivière de
quelle nation autochtone ce qu'elle en
pense la liste est longue mais mais ça
ça va pas se passer avant qu'on sache de
quoi on parle personne peut être contre
la vertu c'est à dire faire une
transition énergétique en se servant de
nos forces et en passant si possible de
venir plus vert et plus riche mais on en
est pas encore rendu même pas à d'autres
choses que que le prologue de ce grand
roman qui va durer des années
Michel ouais ben sur le fond je pense
monsieur Tanguay fait simplement mettre
la table on a besoin d'une grande
conversation nationale sur la transition
énergétique dans le fond elle est déjà
commencé cette conversation là avec le
départ de Madame Brochu les intentions
qu'on prête au gouvernement sur les
barrages etc c'est un débat qui va nous
occuper pendant pas mal de mois sinon
l'année maintenant sur la forme ce qui
me frappe c'est que le sourire de
Monsieur Tanguay il faut comprendre
qu'on est au début d'un mandat ta
prochaine élection est extrêmement loin
que c'est pas le temps là pour
l'opposition je pense de commencer à
chiquer de la gainer la population vient
de choisir un gouvernement et Satan à ce
que les autres parties collaborent dans
la mesure du possible et ça ça me frappe
parce que quand monsieur degault avait
d'abord lancé cette invitation là
c'était quelques jours de la de la
dernière campagne électorale il avait
dit écoutez après l'élection si on était
lu je vais attendre la main au parti
puis on va se rencontrer et tout de
suite madame Anglade à l'époque avait
dit je veux rien savoir de ça c'est de
la récupération là on est loin de la
prochaine élection alors le ton est
évidemment très
différente
la même chose après l'élection qu'avant
monsieur Trudeau Chantal monsieur
Trudeau qui va rencontrer ses ministres
en tête-à-tête est-ce que telle ta tête
à tête
est-ce qu'on peut faire des demi-têtes à
tête selon certains ministres qui ont eu
leur séance de confessionnal aujourd'hui
ça s'est passé à peu près moitié en tête
à tête ce qui est déjà quelque chose là
donc oui quelqu'un du bureau du premier
ministre à certains moments pouvaient
être présent mais il y a eu des périodes
où c'était vraiment
cela avec le Premier ministre ce que moi
je comprends c'est que
essaye de montrer à ces ministres qu'il
est qu'il est non seulement partant mais
qui est lui-même très impliqué dans les
affaires de son gouvernement je vous
ferai remarquer que peut-être que au
cours des 4 5 derniers mois monsieur
Trudeau a passé plus de temps en tête à
tête avec Emmanuel Macron Joe Biden et
compagnie qu'avec ses propres ministres
alors c'est un espèce d'effort
d'essayer de prendre le pouls de l'état
de son conseil des ministres c'est un
exercice un peu inusité et non ça ne
mènera pas je pense que là dessus ceux
qui étaient à l'intérieur et ceux qui
prépareraient les rencontres ont été
clair ce n'est pas le prélude à un
remaniement ministériel qui pourrait
avoir lieu à l'été ou qui pourrait avoir
lieu si quelqu'un pour des raisons de
maladies ou autre est obligé de sortir
ses fonctions ça arrive après les
critiques de Monsieur Morneau dans son
livre qui dit j'ai pas eu l'occasion de
connecter à sec mon patron j'aurais
voulu lui parler alors là une branches
sur tout le monde il va être fatigué à
la fin parce que c'est un gros Conseil
des ministres Michel un mot là Monsieur
Trudeau je le connais pas beaucoup mais
il m'a pas l'air très porté sur les
têtes à tête avec avec ces ministres
comme d'autres l'était où le sont encore
au Canada et au Québec maintenant je
pense que ça va pas si bien que ça pour
Monsieur Trudeau on regarde les sondages
et à part au Québec où là le oui les
libéraux vont bien mais partout ailleurs
au Canada les conservateurs sont en
posture qui demeure en mailleur alors je
pense que Monsieur Trudeau s'y tenté et
je pense qu'il a décidé de rester bah là
il va falloir qu'il soit sûr que toute
sa gang va vraiment être soudée quelle
que soit le moment de l'élection alors
c'est je pense c'est davantage ça
l'objectif qu'un quelconque calcul
remaniement élection à court terme et
puis on lui reprochait puis les
ministres en privé le disent
régulièrement dans lequel monsieur
Trudeau on a l'impression qu'il qu'il
nous regarde pas vraiment il s'occupe
pas de nous José
oui oui c'est ça et je pense que ça
incarne vraiment sa volonté de rester
puis il y a quand même eu des ratés
importants aussi dans la gestion de
certains ministères au cours des
derniers mois on a même pas besoin de
mentionner
l'immigration etc bon donc il a besoin
lui aussi là de solidifier de ressouder
son équipe s'il veut vraiment
mener la bataille à la prochaine
élection je veux je vous fais écouter
madame Arden tout de suite le Premier
ministre la Nouvelle-Zélande qui a
annoncé sa démission en écoute
j'en peux plus très court chacun là
oui je pense que c'est très honnête et
je pense qu'on voit aussi c'est sa vraie
personnalité toujours authentique
toujours très vraie le seulement 42 ans
et je pense qu'il faut considérer qu'il
y a la pandémie aussi la danse a été une
des chefs de gouvernement qui a le mieux
gérer mais ça a dû être absolument
épuisant et drainant sans parler des
attentats terroristes etc donc c'est une
grâce c'est une grande perte mais moi je
salue son honnêteté Chantal
Nouveau-Brunswick qui avait dit j'ai pu
le cas au ventre quand il y avait décidé
de partir après 10 ans mais vous avez
raison c'est rare malgré tout ce qu'on
dit sur Justin Trudeau qui reste ça nous
rappelle que la première question finale
qu'on se pose c'est est-ce que j'ai
encore le coeur à l'ouvrage et c'est pas
une question à laquelle les conseillers
peuvent répondre pour un chef de partie
ou du gouvernement Michel conclusion oui
le petit bout de phrase que qu'on a pas
entendu c'est quand elle le dit ami
human je suis humaine et et
vous avez dit c'est rare qu'on l'entend
d'un homme mais même d'une femme et je
pense que c'est tout à fait c'est rare
point et ça nous ça nous rappelle à quel
point c'est dur la vie politique et
nous sommes nous tous commentateurs on
leur facilite pas la vie non plus
et je pense qu'à un moment donné il est
tout à fait normal que quelqu'un me dise
c'est assez et
c'est pas juste ça dans ma vie et je
vais passer à autre chose je pense c'est
vraiment tout à l'honneur de Madame
c'est rare qu'on voit ça oui tout à fait
et Chantal il reste 15 secondes le fait
qu'elle a dit ne mettez pas ça sur mon
enfant là c'est que je le sens plus là
je veux passer plus de temps avec ma
famille ce qui devrait inspirer d'autres
à ne pas faire ça non plus juste dire
j'ai fait mon temps je vous ai donné ce
que j'avais de mieux et je pourrais pas
être meilleur que j'ai été
bravo merci on a on est justement en
parlant de temps nous voici arrivés à la
fin Chantal Michel josé a très bientôt
merci au revoir bonne soirée pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI